okay who is here because I believe
coming on time and he'll talk with about
stochastic matching with PD dairies and
you have birds and you have 45 minutes
thank you so much I'll give you a five
okay okay thanks hi and good morning I'm
going to talk about stochastic matching
with few queries this is based on joint
works with ali reza muhammad ali Hajiyev
i'm advisor and Nima
i will start with a setting which is
pretty simple we are given a graph G and
a probability P and each edge of the
square G is realized independently with
poverty P so basically we have this
impact graph and a subset of its edges
are going to be realized independently
from each other we know what the input
graph is but we have no idea what the
realization looks like and we can learn
about it by querying each edge right so
we can query each edge see whether it's
realized or not
our goal is to find a large matching in
this realized graph and at the same time
we don't want to query too many edges
that's what this is the setting
basically also I I'll be mostly talking
about non adaptive algorithms meaning
that you cannot for example query one
edge see what the result is and then
decide what other edge to query so all
of the queries should be conducted at
the same time all right so this is the
non adaptive setting of the problem and
in other words the problem is really
that we are given this graph G we would
like to esparza Phi it into a sub graph
H and query the edges in H and we would
like to maximize this ratio what is this
ratio it has the maximum realized
matching size in this sub graph H over
the maximum realized matching size of G
is everything clear so this is also
called the approximation factor and our
measure of a sparsity of H is maximum
degree right so we would like to make
sure that we have not we do not query
too many edges connected to a single
vertex right this is the setting I'll
now talk about some application so for
example the first application is in
kidney exchange suppose that we have
donor patient pairs that are
incompatible now if in the compatibility
graph we find in a simplest case that
pairwise exchanges if you find a
matching in this in the compatibility
graph the donors for each edge in this
matching the donors can exchange your
kidneys with the patients of the other
pair right so if you find a large
matching everyone will receive kidneys
and we were happy the problem is that
you're not aware of what this
compatibility graph looks like right and
we'd like to learn about
so let me first start that start by
saying that you can't look up at the
database on for example say well a
priori say that this pair these two
pairs are not going to be compatible
because for example their blood types
don't match that's that's not all the
story even the edges that are not rule
that yet may not actually be compatible
and to see whether these edges are
compatible or not a more expensive
medical test known as the cross match
test is required which includes for
example mixing the actual Bloods of the
pair's and see what happens okay so we
cannot have these tests for every pair
of donair patient pairs right so we'd
like to in a sense query very few edges
of this graph see whether these edges
are realized whether they're compatible
with each other or not I find a large
matching so this is the precisely the
model that I described so in other words
we would like to esparza Phi this graph
for example pick only these edges query
them see which one of them are realized
and among what's left we report a
maximum match right
another application is online labour
markets so for example suppose that we
have a set of free dancers and a set of
clients for the priory again we can rule
out some of these edges so for example
this client has a specified a subset of
skills required by the freelancer so we
can't rule out some of the edges but the
edges that remain are not necessarily
indicators that any two vertices can
work with each other so for that and
more expensive interview process is
required so now suppose that we would
like to suggest who each client NH
freelancer should interview a natural
objective is that we would like to
recommend very few interviews per person
and at the center we would like to
achieve a very large matching right so
this is also criticized at the same
model so enough for the applications so
let's see some so this is really a
trade-off right so more the more edges
that you query the better approximation
factor so this is really a trade-off
between the number of clues yes yes any
other questions
so a trivial algorithm is just set H to
be G query every edge okay so the good
thing is that we find the maximum
matching the bad thing is that the
degree is too large we don't want that
another algorithm is well pick this for
this graph H just pick a maximal
matching of G and query only the edges
in that magic the good thing is that for
every verse you query only one edge the
bad thing is you only get a P
approximation only P fraction of the
edges of this matching will be realized
that's on the the matching it define the
original graph may have a very large in
fact it can be shown that if we want to
get a constant approximation to this
matching size we have to query at this
Omega 1 over P edges per vertex why if
you fix a vertex each edge is realized
with party P if you query less than one
over P edges there is a constant
priority that this vertex will be seeing
it so none of those edges will realize
so if you want to avoid that you'd have
to query at this one over P edges
perfectly lower bound what else can we
do another natural game is just a sample
save on over P edges per vertex
uniformly at random this actually can be
shown to provide only a 0 approximation
as the size of the graph increases this
was even if the number of samples is too
dirty even if it's say root n the
operation factor is again zero it's so
nothing useful
it can be shown that non-trivial useful
algorithms can be given for this problem
so the first work of plummeted which
introduced this model of Kazakh matching
problem in their work they showed that
and half approximation can be achieved
with a non adaptive algorithm at the
number of queries is pulley of one over
P so I guess this epsilon is a constant
this is probably one over P and later it
was shown that even a linear dependence
on P gives us the same approximation
factor but as I do tell who also showed
next year that this half approximation
can be working you can get half plus
some absolute constant larger than zero
approximation using the same number of
queries again just this half
approximation is really a barrier for
this problem like many different
settings of the matching problem this
was a very nice result later last year
we showed that you can get significantly
better than half this is what I'll be
mostly talking about so you can get 0.62
568 approximation and this was also
improved to 2/3 right so this is this is
what we know about the unweighted graph
so we can get the two third
approximation by querying edges
proportional only to peep for exam you
don't need any dependence on the graphs
of structure the number of vertices or
nothing else for the weighted graphs the
earlier works require dependence on or
example maximum weight in the graph or
log n but later it was shown that well
similar bounds can be achieved for the
way that case as well so for example we
showed that a half approximation
algorithm can be achieved by querying
again poly one over P queries so I get
the substance some constant
and we actually show that this the same
algorithm it's natural generalization to
general graph to general beta graphs
also breaks half for weighted graphs
this is this is what's basically known
for this problem an interesting fact is
that all of this works as I've
highlighted here and I just analyze
essentially the same algorithm right and
I go actually soon talk about it differ
significantly but only in the analysis
so it's not know whether that's it's
quite possible as 1 minus epsilon
extinction can also be achieve have no
bad example but we're just not there yet
and yeah and next I just focus on this
algorithm and provide outlines of the
proof there is there is no W in the
approximation that's that that's the
number of queries per vertex okay so
it's the maximum weight in the graph if
your graph is weighted you'd pick what
the maximum integer rate is in the graph
and that's proportion to the number of
edges that occur
so this is the first algorithm that I'm
going to talk about this was precisely
the algorithm analyzed in this green
works it's very natural so you pick a
maximum matching each way so you pick a
maximum matching from the graph remove
all of its edges
pick another maximal matching from the
remaining graph remove all of its edges
repeat this for all rounds put all these
matchings together and query them at the
same time
more precisely you first copy the graph
G into this other graph G Prime and then
iterate to pick a maximum matching of
this graph say this blue match ink put
it into H and then remove them from G
Prime you repeat this again and this
example is actually important so let's
go over it again so originally the
maximum matching in this graph is
perfect right so this is the perfect
matching you pick this perfect match and
put it into H and remove it again we
have another perfect matching all right
so you pick this perfect matching put it
into H now at this point the matching
size of this graph drops significantly
this is not there is no perfect matching
anymore
half of the vertices here cannot be
matched to any vertex and the same a
story holds for this side note that this
maximum matching gets picked is any
arbitrary maximum matching so let's pick
this matching first put it into H again
pick another matching very similar to
the previous matching put it into H I
repeat this for all rounds eventually
this is the graph that we would query so
let's see what the approximation factor
is for this example so I first claimed
that suppose a P is 1/2 I first claimed
that the expected maximum realized
matching of this graph is almost perfect
where besides if 1 minus little Oban
fraction of the vertices will be matched
in the realized graph of this why is
that well P is 1/2 so half of these
edges will be realized in expectation
and using a simple charm you can prove
that very it's very concentrated around
half a fraction of them so very close to
half of this edges we reveal has just
put them in the matching well does that
mean it means that half of the vs. here
will be a matched
and between them and the verses here
there's a complete bipartite graph now
even if you remove half of these edges
uniformly at random
you can still prove that halls theorem
holds and you can get a near perfect
matching Bhatinda
the same holds for this side so
eventually get a perfect matching on
this graph but this sub graph that we
query using this algorithm so if you
look at these vertices they have degree
only two so there's a probability 1/4
that none of these edges connected to
each of these vertices is realized so
each of them has a priority 1/4 of being
singleton are not being matched so the
matching that we find by querying this
subset of edges cannot provide an
arbitrary for example good approximation
I just found it away from one by some
large cost
and besides that all the all the works
that improve over this half
approximation use different algorithm it
turns out to be very hard to argue that
it achieves anything better than half
approximation though there is no offer
by matching half so it's a parameter of
the algorithm so you can repeat it as
many times as you want this R will be
precisely the number of queries that you
contact a vertex right so for example in
this work it was shown that if this is
your R you get this approximation if
this perfect if you're if you set R to
be 1 over P to 2 over epsilon you get a
half approximation later it was shown
that if R is only 1 over Epsilon P you
get the same approximation so this is
what this works actually analyze what is
the value what's the correct value of R
for achieving for example this
approximation
now I'm going to talk about the second
algorithm this is also very simple and
note that the previous algorithm was
deterministic so you iterate a to pick a
deterministic maximum matching remove
its edges and continue but this
algorithm that I'm going to describe
incorporates a randomization to the
process so what do we do we first draw
our realizations of the graph this is
only part of the algorithm these
realizations have nothing to do with the
actual realization which we compare our
algorithm so you just sample our
different realizations independently
from each other and for each of these
realizations you pick a maximal match
from exactly the same distribution and
you find maximum matching of each of
these realizations the union of these
matchings will be about your query
so for the same example what happens is
that if you fix any of these vertices in
the middle in half of the realizations
they have to be matched to the outside
versus so if you fix this vertex if this
edge is not realized you have to match
it to a various outside so if you repeat
this for R times for each of these
verses you expect roughly R over two
edges to the vertices outside so the
same problem doesn't occur for this
example and can be shown that this for
this example we can actually prove all
my self self exams
and again on emphasize that this first
line of the algorithm is part of the
randomization of the algorithm and for
the analysis we need this second part to
be deterministic so you pick a
deterministic maximum matching accurate
so then the graph on the right H isn't
it true that with positive probability
some of those horizontal edges would not
exist
yes exactly half of these verses will
not be realized that we can again argue
that these those half of the edges that
are not realized their vertices can be
matched to the outside vertices so we
have 1 over P R of the random edges you
can't find a very large matching in the
square the mark realized for any
particular realization right maybe over
a bunch of matches you actually
questions
so given analysis outlined for this
algorithm I first prove that this
algorithm match is a half approximation
but the ideas for arguing that we get a
better than half approximation is
basically a generalization of the idea
that I'm going to describe you if there
is time I will actually provide more
details so define for each edge e define
Q sub e to be the probability that it
joins the maximum realized magic so this
this is independent of the algorithm
right so this is your given this graph
and you know for each realization what's
matching algorithm is used and again
suppose that this is a deterministic
matching maximum matching algorithm for
each edge you cannot define the
probability that it appears and this max
so much so this is Q so this is your
graph how do you construct the maximum
matching you first see what are these
edges outside that I realize you put
them in the matching and then try to
fill in between those vertices that are
not matched using the these edges in the
middle right so if P is half for each of
these edges so long as they're real as
you put them in a matching where it's
like you saw before damn will be half
which size you have and for these edges
in the middle Q sub is much smaller just
for this very specific example it's less
than point zero zero six okay so what we
do is that we set this threshold tar to
be Delta P for some small constant Delta
say point zero one right if an edge has
Q sub II smaller than tau we call it non
crucial otherwise we call it crucial so
for example in this graph these edges
will be crucial they appear in most of
the matching edge they appear in the
matching of most realizations but these
edges in the middle are non crucial even
if you get rid of a few of them nothing
really changes
you know let's have a few observations
on this definition first of all observe
that each edge II appears in each sample
of the algorithm precisely with this
probability Q II so we are drawing this
realization from exactly the same
distribution I'm finding matching using
the same sorry deterministic algorithm
so the probability that this edge
appears in each of those samples of the
algorithm is precisely equal to the
priority that it appears in the actual
realization very simple and the second
nice observation is that you can't think
of this Q as a very fraction as a really
fractional matching of this graph why is
that well
each of these Q's is the probability so
it's between 0 and 1 and we also have to
show for it to be a valued fraction on
matching that the sum of Q is connected
to a vertex does not exceed 1 which is
also very easy to show why each vertex
is matched at most once in each
realization so some of these
probabilities cannot exceed 1 another
way of proving this is that this Q is
really a linear combination of integral
matchings over different realizations so
not only it's a valid fraction watching
if your graph is general you can simply
show that even the blosum inequalities
are satisfied and the third observation
is the sum of these Q is equal to opt so
I define opt to be expected realize
matching size of graph G very simple
argument shows that some of these Q is
is equal to opt right is it clear
again we partitioned the edges into
crucial and non crucial and we used two
different analysis for crucial and on
crucial edges so the first one is
actually very simple which we call the
crucial edges demo what we show is that
well this algorithm if you said are to
be larger than roughly 1 over tau this
is the threshold that we fix for
defining whether an edge is crucial or
not crucial if you fix R to be larger
than this 1 over tau times log of 1 over
Epsilon you can't prove that
so essentially 1 minus epsilon fraction
of crucial edges are all sampled by the
algorithm
it's very simple to prove why fix
ecology the probability that it's not
sampled by the algorithm what is it
so fix the first sample of the algorithm
probability that this edge does not
appear in that sample is 1 minus QE
again huy what to assess the property
that it appears on this really in the
sample the particulate does not appear
in this realization is 1 minus Q and we
have our independent samples the
property that it does not appear in any
of them as this much now this Q sub E is
this edge is crucial so by definition
Q's of E is larger than tau so this you
can replace it with tau and have this
inequality and R is also going to be
larger than this amount and if you
replace that here you get at the
probability that this crucial edge is
not sampled by the algorithm is a
smaller than Epsilon
simpler argument is about each crucial
edge has Q sub a larger than toe
how many crucial edges can be connected
to each vertex one a retired must
because some of them cannot exceed one
so you can just query all of them an
algorithm B naturally does this because
it's samples these edges in the matching
proportionally to accuse of these second
we can't be query almost all the crucial
edges to whatever that we expect on the
crucial edges appears out whatever what
exactly the fraction of the crucial is
that appears in the actual matching of
the graph G appears also in our sample
in the algorithm B we have a similar
lemma on non crucial edges namely we can
also argue that the matching returned by
our algorithm they realize matching in
those sampled edges where the algorithm
is at least as large as some of what's
written some some of qyz of the non
crucial edges well the proof is very
different so let me go over it in more
details so define n to be the expected
number of non crucial edges that appear
in the optimal matching right so this n
is equal precisely to some of these qyz
of all non crucial edges this is the
portion of edges of each matching of the
original graph G realization of the
original graph G that are non crucial
the claim here is that the expected size
of the realized matching of the sub
graph retain by algorithm B this graph H
is at least for myself sometimes n so we
get almost all non crucial edges as well
observer here the story is very
different from crucial edges because to
a vertex we can have as many as n Omega
n non crucial edges right so in this
example all of these edges in the middle
are non crucial the ik u is our various
small proportional to 1 over n but you
cannot just ignore them because some of
these Q is is very large nonetheless
what we show in this lemma is that even
though we sample a very small fraction
of these edges the matching constructed
on a realization of them is as large as
what we see here as large as some of
these Q is on these edges
how do we prove this
so define f sub e to be the fraction of
samples in the algorithm that have this
edge e in their maximal matching recall
that the algorithm picks our different
samples on each it picks a maximum
matching right so for each edge defined
F sub e to be the fraction of these are
samples that include this edge e square
so now now is the time B so this graph H
has been determined we now reveal what
the actual realization is it is a random
variable of the randomization in the
algorithm now we reveal the whole
realization of the graph and on each
realized non crucial edge we write the
following fractional value right what is
this value we write F sub e times 1 over
P ISOFIX at reason on crucial edge if it
is realized we write this value on it
this this actually has some cool
properties the first observation is that
if an edge is not sampled by the
algorithm we write zero on it it appears
in zero fraction of the samples so f sub
e for that edge is zero so we don't
write anything on that edge I'm actually
going to argue that this X can be
thought of as a fractional matching on
the realized graph on those edges that
have been sampled by the algorithm so
this is really the solution that we get
so all these edges that are not queried
by the algorithm we write zero on them
all the non zero values are written on
these edges that are also in addition
realized next fix
any arbitrary edge any an arbitrary non
crucial edge right and this expectation
is taken over both the randomization of
the algorithm and the random using the
actual realization my claim is that this
expected value of what we write on this
edge is precisely equal to Q so beyond
that edge why is that well so the probe
what's what's this value of e first it
has to be realized by definition we only
write this value on the realized edges
so it has to be realized and then if
it's realized what do we write on it we
write f sub e times 1 over P so this is
1 over P and what is the value of F so P
so we admit this expectation is taken
over the randomization of the algorithm
and all of these are independent so you
can just this so the probability that G
is realized as precisely P what is the
expected value of F sub P F sub E is the
fraction of those samples that include e
what is the probability that it appears
in the first sample it is precisely Q
sub V this is an observation we talked
about earlier so the fraction of them
that include this edge a precisely
equals Q so V so in each one of them it
appears the priority Q so P so we
expected to appear in exactly Q sub e
fraction of those samples so this we can
replace with Q sub E and that we have
this one over Peter so the P is canceled
out and this is equal to Q so V right so
any edge that you fix in expectation
what you write on it is equal to Q so V
so what does this mean this means that
using a very simple linear shape
expectation argument you can show that
some of these q is written on the graph
is as large as sum of Q is under non
crucial edges this is equal to n so
again so we know that this X is only
written on the edges that have been
sampled by the algorithm and have been
realized and we know that what we write
on them is as large as what we want yeah
they're all non crucial even if you take
the summation over non crucial adjust
this is going to be this large
we only need to argue that this is a
valid fractional magic right this is
where we need these edges to be done
crucial all of the arguments up to here
were given for now four crucial edges
but this is where we need them to be non
crucial right so since the edges are non
crucial qyz are very small much smaller
than Q sub E and you can also show that
f sub is are very also small say a
smaller than epsilon P it's a set the
treasure to be small enough so that you
can guarantee that for most say 1 minus
epsilon fraction of the vertices F sub
is are going to be a smaller than
Epsilon ok now what we get is that if
since this holds so you have a set of
random variables each of them is
realized with priority P and if you real
if they are realized you multiply their
value the f sub e value by 1 over P
because these are bounded away from P
the expected value of each of these
random variables is bounded away from P
using a simple journal point you can
prove that the probability that exceeds
for example 1 plus epsilon is at most
Epsilon
things like that sort of dependence so
overall what this means is that this X
is really a valid fractional matching
and again so we want this to happen so
they have to be non crucial so this F
sub is should not be close to P they
should be much smarter damp you say
epsilon P and then you can use a turn
upon and say that they don't exceed
so
so is everything clear so we've just
proved what did we do we prove that you
take these non crucial edges those that
are sampled by the algorithm in each
realization you can write a fractional
matching on them that is as large as the
N so if you have a fractional matching
of size s X on a graph that all you have
you can also show that all the blossom
inequalities hold but ignoring that
suppose that the graph is bipartite if
you have a fractional matching of size X
on a graph
Edwin's theorem tells us that you also
have an integral matching of size X for
the general case so so yeah we can also
construct this large matching under non
crucial edges so what does this imply so
we had this so define C to be sum of Q
is under crucial edges and n to be sum
of Q is under non crucial edges so the
crucial edges lemma tells us that the
sample all the crucial edges right
roughly so they expected realized
matching on H which samples all of them
is as large as this C 1 minus Epsilon
see the non crucial edges lemma tells us
that the realized matching of H is
larger than 1 minus epsilon n we also
get all the non crucial edges and by
definition opt is equal to C plus n each
edge is either crucial or non crucial
opt is equal to some of you is right so
it's equal to C plus n so either C is
more than half of ops or n is more than
half of Oaks in either way we get this
half of all using one of these two lines
right so the in the end what we get is
that the realized matching of H is at
least half of this gets half
approximation
well what we want is really to get
better than half operation so this
approximation could have been achieved
using much simpler analysis and much
simpler algorithms with the essence of
our analysis was the fraction of
matching construction of those
fractional matches of the skirt for the
non crucial edges so you can actually
generalize that to incorporate also the
crucial edges right so you can what we
do so what we did was that you you had
this graph H constructed by the
algorithm that took some realizations
some matchings over some realizations I
returned this graph H and we have this
realization of this graph H we designed
the procedure so this was the procedure
of constructing that fractional match we
designed the procedure that took these
two values these two graphs and
constructs a large fractional matching
on graph H sub so in a sense we are
giving an algorithm to analyze the
performance of algorithm P so we call
these algorithms procedures so with the
more involved procedure that also again
incorporates crucial edges we can end up
with a procedure that we can prove gets
a point sixty five approximation of opt
and the the the rough idea behind it is
that you first construct the same
fractional matching under non crucial
edges first you get what is whatever
that's under non crucial edges and in
addition you have this property that the
fractional value that you write and
around each vertex does not exceed some
of qyz of non crucial edges connected to
that vertex if you have that you can now
fill in whatever that's left by crucial
edges okay so you draw matching from the
crucial edges that I realized you
increase the fraction on matching on
them as much as you can
that does not violate vertex budgets the
analysis is much more complicated but
then you can't prove that using this
against simple procedure you can get a
point sixty five sixty eight
approximation and for this procedure to
be sure that this is tight you cannot
argue that it's better well this is
tight for the procedure we don't know
what the true representative factor of
the algorithm is its but for this
procedure this is tight
and again the same algorithm works for
varied graphs right so you draw
realizations of the graph on each one
now instead of a matching you pick a
maximal weighted matching again the same
what I described actually gives a half
approximation but using a more about
procedure you can prove that you can
actually get past half opportunity for
greater graphs to in conclusion so we
proposed this algorithm B which we show
that shaves with more than 65
approximation for invader graphs and 0.5
plus some constant approximation for
radar graphs but the most important open
question clearly is whether we can get 1
minus epsilon approximation for weighted
graphs
but before that we first have to answer
whether we can break this to third
approximation and this was important
because this two-third approximation is
a barrier in many different settings so
it turns out that for example in the
communication complexity setting you
have two parties each gets a subset of
the graph they want to report a maximum
a [ __ ] and one has to send a subset of
the edges to the other party you'd have
to prove you can't prove that if you
only sign the matching if you only set
in a sub graph of size of the O of N or
even slightly larger you cannot break
2/3 so here the same as sorry almost all
right so you have crucial edges and non
crucial edges you want to use them to
occupy at each other right but this is
this is not a precise upper bound it's a
stale quiet possible L bar minus F
sniper to me it can be achieved yes but
this is this is something that we don't
know how to get past using for money get
passed away and another open question is
what's the true approximation fabulous
algorithm B can we have an example where
this algorithm does not get Obama
reception approximation we don't know
thank so what's the algorithm for the
two-thirds approximation for unweighted
processes just like your algorithm no
it's a very different algorithm describe
it is not very simple to describe but
you pick a subgraph such as roughly the
sum of degrees of every edge in the
graph is not too large and the sum of
degrees of every edge not in the graph
under both sides is not too small
but that's algorithm not really one
general graph does not achieve anything
better than 2/3 so that algorithm is
settled almost
so if I think of this effect of having a
graphical model value has an independent
agents coalition is zero you have this
any heartless move or even mice
correlation of crosshedges
okay so so there so I think you can't
prove that
if only there are constructions that if
only the edges inside one matching so
suppose that you're given this graph G
and one matching known to the algorithm
and everything the P fraction of the
edges inside this algorithm are not
chosen independently from each other and
this extended model you can prove that
to 30 sides
you cannot break
so one is a quick I have two questions
one is would you bet on your algorithm
make 1 minus epsilon or again sir
and the other is can you get a 1 minus
epsilon you know provably on locally
tree like graphs again like do you think
it's possible so for the first question
I think is well I don't have any bad
eggs I don't have any example where it
doesn't provide of all myself some
operation and if you think of it it's
very hard to construct the examples but
it doesn't achieve a one myself in
operation because you're drawing this
matching precisely from the same
distribution and yeah my conjecture is
that it should get about myself some
approximation Part B but yeah this is
just the conjecture for the second one
we we have another paper we show that if
the graph has a bounded arbor acity you
can get by minus of snipers image
the same algorithm no it's a different I
guess like I find this algorithm so
natural I would almost be interested in
a result that describes a large class of
instances or its optimal like maybe even
rent them like on some random crap
structures like it seems much better
than the 2/3 algorithm intuitively I
agree
okay thank you very much cool we have